là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux ni j'aimerais
beaucoup qu'ils y en a très bien tricoté
à votre classe la rame et non un peu
moins mais si vous ne réussissez pas
c'est qu'il vous manque qu'une seule
chose un tout petit détail le front fais
les valises à paris arrive à la bulle
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cet
inattendu aujourd'hui nous allons vous
montrer comment le plastique désormais
si décrié a longtemps été présenté comme
très pratique nous parlerons aussi du
mannequinat top model du rêve à la
réalité manon renault journaliste va
nous expliquer bien tout ce qui se cache
derrière les images des défilés vu à la
télévision mais d'abord notre
traditionnelle revue de presse avec
ludivine et camille journaliste à la
rédaction dina bonjour à vous alors
qu'est ce qui a retenu l'attention de
l'ina cette semaine est bien moins
d'avoir lavé envie de revenir sur les
400 ans de jean baptiste poquelin dit
molière
c'était le 15 janvier 1622 alors on ne
connaît pas précisément sa date de
naissance donc on fait la date de son
baptême molière c'est en aujourd'hui
encore l'un des auteurs les plus joués
dans le monde est un homme veut qu'on
reconnaisse son génie regarder francis
huster il veut qu il entre au panthéon
molière donc le génie de molière c'est
d'avoir mis sur scène la langue du
peuple et bien cette langue du peuple
francis huster il en parlait déjà en
1992 il disait qu'il fallait dire aux
jeunes d'aller voir du théâtre d'aller
voir du molière plutôt que d'écouter la
parole des hommes politiques je pense
que si molière était là aujourd'hui lui
ne l'empêcherait pas en tout cas de dire
à certains hommes politiques ce qu'ils
pensent de leur attitude peut-être
maintenant les hommes politiques vont
commencer à comprendre qu'on peut plus
parler avec le langage de la lâcheté ou
la compromission ou l'hypocrisie
les jeunes ne supporte plus et les
jeunes aussi ont une mission on leur
demande de voter pour prendre leurs
responsabilités et on leur demande aussi
de venir au théâtre
pour écouter ce qu'un génie agit ni
quelqu'un qui parle sans sans nous en
phase semblable à ces c'est justement le
contraire de ce qu'on peut imaginer du
tout du théâtre de la poussière c'est
pas vrai le théâtre en france c'est
vraiment le paradis voilà on verra si
emmanuel macron écoute francis huster et
pente et aunis ce génie de la langue
française qui molière en tout cas
beaucoup de conviction dans ses propos
autre sujet qui a marqué l'actualité ces
derniers jours ludivine les les
embouteillages parisiens oui il y en a
beaucoup y aura beaucoup ça on ne fait
malheureusement et je voulais vous en
parler parce qu'ils ont fait l'objet
donc ses embouteillages d'une énième
étude publiée cette semaine dans le
parisien le résultat est sans surprise
vous vous en doutez on peut mettre 40
minutes pour faire 4 km dans le ciel et
captiva l'otan effectivement elle y
aller à pied fin 2021 une autre étude
décerné déjà à paris le deuxième le
titre pardon de la deuxième ville la
plus embouteillée du monde après londres
alors les bouchons les embouteillages on
en parle à la télévision depuis
longtemps en 1970 un reportage
décryptait ce phénomène de société
faris le cas extrême mais c'est aussi ce
que commencent à connaître les grandes
villes de france marseille lyon bordeaux
lille aux heures de pointe dans le
centre ville chaque jour des
embouteillages des heures et des heures
perdues ici dans leur région parisienne
deux millions cinq cent mille véhicules
circulent chaque jour or déjà les rues
sont encombrées le coeur de paris est
asphyxié fois qu'on doive être
permanent avec les honneurs
une ville paralysée par les voitures ce
n'est pas une caricature un exemple si
aujourd'hui à paris aux heures de pointe
aux automobilistes au lieu de 10 décidé
de prendre leur voiture
toute circulation dans la ville seraient
bloqués
cinquante ans plus tard visiblement ça
n'a pas vraiment changé dans la capitale
et on va continuer à parler
d'environnement dans quelques minutes en
votre compagnie voilà pour l'actualité
de cette semaine alors que s'est il
passé à cette même période de l'année
par le passé et bien regardez c'est le
zapping de l'inattendu
bonjour
51 états ont délégué leurs représentants
à londres
c'est le premier britannique monsieur
attali qui prononça le discours
inaugural une troisième guerre mondiale
dit-il notamment arrêtera et pour des
siècles la marche de la civilisation
nous ne pouvons plus être liée par le
traité de non prolifération nucléaire
les coréens du nord assurent qu'ils
n'ont pas l'intention de produire des
armes nucléaires mais aujourd'hui en
sortant du traité il s'en donne le droit
voici les dernières images reçues
d'haïti selon les témoignages aucun
bâtiment à étages n'a résisté tous les
grands édifices publics ont été détruits
le centre-ville est jonchée de cadavres
et deux blessés à bord thierry sabine
jean paul le fur le radio
françois xavier bagnoud
le pilote
daniel balavoine
et nathalie odeur du journal du dimanche
[Musique]
tous les 500 morts au cours de
l'inauguration officielle cet après midi
jacques higelin a essuyé les plâtres
sur la terre l'ancienne tête en l'air
[Musique]
[Rires]
les soixante huitards garderont l'image
d'un professeur choron cofondateur avec
avanade hara kiri puis charlie hebdo en
face qu'à drôle tu vois par exemple on
meurt aujourd'hui tout le monde parle de
nous donc il faut vraiment là pourquoi
parle de toi bonsoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'une des mesures phares de ce
début d'année les emballages plastiques
pour les fruits et les légumes de moins
de 1 kg 5 sont désormais interdits après
les pailles et les couverts en plastique
ça c'était l'an passé voici donc une
nouvelle mesure de la loi anti
gaspillage ludivine la chasse aux
plastiques continue c'est même l'ennemi
écologique numéro un oui et pour cause
selon l'onu environ 8 millions de tonnes
de déchets plastiques finissent chaque
année dans les océans et en dépit des
progrès en matière de recyclage ou
d'interdiction des produits à usage
unique ce volume de déchets pourrait
tripler d'ici
2040 alors vous l'avez dit nathanaël
pour toute la planète le plastique est
devenu l'ennemi écologique numéro un
mais souvenez-vous à une époque c'était
loin d'être le cas le plastique c'était
plutôt
nous vivons aujourd'hui le dans du
plastique
1956 le temps du plastique inspire léo
ferré
c'est bien plus fantastique que type que
tiken y voit le printemps passé son
temps à perdre et albert des leurs sans
pipe à cette époque le plastique est en
plein essor et la france participe
activement à sa production c'est même
une fierté nationale les nouvelles
usines sont inaugurés en grande pompe
cette usine de cause n'a rien à envier
aux installations américaines ça presse
la plus importante d'europe supporter
une pression de 4000 tonnes soit le
poids de 40 locomotives en 1960 à en
croire les reportages de l'époque la
france a produit trois cent mille tonnes
de plastique le matériau ne présentent
alors que des qualités la matière
plastique est donc bien résistantes pour
assumer toutes ses responsabilités et
toutes ses fonctions tous ces usages
terriblement résistante plus résistantes
plus économique les matières plastiques
envahissent le quotidien des français
elles sont partout le monsieur qui
conduit sa voiture la ménagère qui
passent l'aspirateur ou qui nous sont
café l'enfant qui joue l'enfant qui rêve
aussi chacun dépend déjà de cette chimie
des grosses molécules récente mais en
plein essor même la mode s'y met la
femme des années 60 sera plastifié
jamais sans doute le polystyrène et le
chlorure de vinyle ne s'était trouvé en
aussi agréable compagnie l'air est au
tout jetable emballages bouteilles rien
ne se gardent à la bouteille dit hier
qu'il fallait récupérer laver au prix
d'une manutention coûteuse succède
aujourd'hui aux inventaires la bouteille
que l'on jette purement et simplement
la vie moderne et la grande ennemie du
temps perdu et le jour n'est peut-être
pas si loin où le repas terminé le
couvert au même titre que la bouteille
retournera aussitôt sonné 1 expéditif et
tellement reposant
des salons entier sont dédiés aux objets
plastiques c'est le matériau roi vivre
sans inimaginable
regardez ce qui se passerait si on avait
plus les matières plastiques
[Musique]
mais qui dit plastique dit déchets ils
sont nombreux et à partir des années
soixante dix le plastique va devenir un
peu moins fantastique
après l'essor du plastique dans les
années 50-60 justement une prise de
conscience s'opère dans les années 60
oui enfin une prise de conscience
relativement progressive
il ya surtout à cette époque les
premières interrogations autour de
l'utilisation massive des matières
plastiques les missions
environnementales la france défigurée
consacré même une enquête à ce phénomène
en 1973 vous voyez ici les images donc
de l'émission la france défigurée la
question des traitements des déchets du
recyclage était largement abordée mais
aussi celle de la pollution plastique ce
qu'il faut noter aussi c'est qu'à cette
époque il y avait surtout les premières
alertes comme celle du volcanologue
sensible aux questions écologiques
haroun tazieff écoutez le c'était en
1974 mon métier de jeu love me fait
parcourir la planète et me fait aller
dans des endroits où en principe aucune
pollution ne devrait pas revenir dans la
mer rouge depuis des années par un
bateau pratiquement ne pas essayer en
mer rouge s'est pas levé vous avez vous
avez du mazout qui flottent vous avez
angle ou dans le sud de la mer rouge
vous avez dû des plastique qui flottent
récemment j'étais dans le sud de l'océan
pacifique c'était la même chose la
pollution gagne le bien le plus précieux
de l'humanité qui est l'eau visionnaire
7 haroun tazieff on ne cesse de le dire
en tout cas cinquante ans après cette
alerte la pollution plastique dans les
océans ne cesse de s'intensifier une
pollution qu'on retrouve aussi dans nos
organismes selon la fondation wwf
on n'en gérait accrochez-vous 5 grammes
par semaine de plastique c'est
l'équivalent d'une carte bleue merci à
vous
petite information comment réagir à ça
j'avoue je crois que j'ai un peu pris de
court no ha oui ça c'est clair on
attendait pas on l'a pas vu venir celle
le mois de janvier c'est le mois de la
mode à paris les fashion weeks en chaîne
à partir de la semaine prochaine
occasion de parler d'un métier qui fait
souvent rêver et pas que les jeunes
filles le mannequinat bonjour maintenant
renault journaliste spécialiste des
questions de mode vous enseignez
également à la sorbonne heures c'est une
question récurrente dans les archives
sur tous les mannequins ge alors je vous
la pose aussi est-ce que mannequin c'est
un métier alors évidemment c'est un
métier c'est un métier mais qui n'est
pas reconnue réellement en tant que tel
en tout cas qui culturellement
historiquement n'a jamais été apprécié
en tant que métier c'est plutôt vu comme
une passion et comme c'est vraiment liés
au corps et que sa demande ça repose sur
le corps ça repose pas sur l'esprit donc
du coup ce n'est pas vu comme un métier
s'est plutôt rapproché l'un des métiers
du corps qu'on connaît tous en tout cas
mannequin mannequinat
camille ça inspire les journalistes et
les télévisions les archives de l'ina
sont riches sur ce sujet oui ça inspire
ça attise la curiosité des journalistes
alors on va planter le décor au sortir
de la guerre les défilés sont encore
intimiste confidentiel réservé à une
certaine classe aux acheteurs
essentiellement et les mannequins sont
là uniquement pour présenter les
vêtements aux acheteuses le changement
c'est surtout dans les années 50 le
prêt-à-porter arrive la mode se
popularise et puis surtout la mode se
médiatise et avec ça le mannequinat va
faire rêver toute une génération de
jeunes femmes et certaines vont
apprendre ce métier dans des écoles en
1956 un journaliste se rend dans l'une
de ces écoles regarder
un mannequin ça ne mange pas ça boit
sexe et frivole dans le meilleur cas
l'on se fait épouser par un quelconque
milliardaire évidemment on peut se
demander ce qu'en pensent les intéressés
eux mêmes nous avons le mois de janvier
est très dur nous préparons les
collections de prato comment sont très
tôt le matin
à l'apprentissage elle doit être préparé
elle doit à mon point de vue faire
beaucoup de culture physique georges
duby
je pense si on n'arrive pas du jour au
lendemain être mannequin il faut
quelquefois plusieurs mois plusieurs
années moi même j'ai mis quatre
voilà un mannequin ça ne mange pas on
l'attend c'est frivole on entend à
priori le second degré au début mais
tout de même le mannequinat est à cheval
entre le statut à demi-mot de filles
faciles et le statut de mannequin c'est
un peu dégradant quand même c'est tout à
fait dégradants et ça ne concerne pas
l'intellect ça concerne le corps c'est
toujours cette opposition qui est fait
et les mannequins sont vus comme des
femmes objets en essentiellement comme
des femmes objets qui résulte des
fantasmes des couturiers ouais et ça
c'est ce qui va coller d'ailleurs la
profession est encore aujourd'hui cette
image de jeune femme un peu sotte en
fait qui défilent et qui n'ont qu'un
corps a montré en 1964 un journaliste
interroge un mannequin justement sur son
métier et écouter la franchise avec
laquelle elle lui répond parce que vous
avez la passion dans votre travail de
n'être que des objets
aussi
les objets
de quoi sans se couper les cheveux on
faire
j'étais vraiment la pâte à modeler puis
toi le jour 2 quand tu présentes tu
apportes quelque chose mais avant on te
ne modifient en tas modeler tu présentes
la boisson dont on a fait quelque chose
de toi et là dessus tu parles là dessus
et à toi tu de mettre en valeur ce qu'on
a voulu te rend plus compte à apporter
mais ça vous manque pas de ne travailler
qu'avec votre corps de ne pas travailler
avec votre esprit intelligence et je me
moque elle est folle cette parole
décomplexée en 1964 moi j'ai jamais
entendue aujourd'hui de mannequins
afficher clairement les choses très
clairement comme ça de face à un
journaliste alors effectivement ça assez
étonnant pour les années 60 on peut dire
ça mais en même temps un moment où la
mode change il ya le prêt-à-porter il ya
un mouvement aussi plus jeunes
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que l'on
voit à quel point aussi des filles ne
veulent peut être simplement la vision
artistique d'un créateur elle ne le met
en mots on est classé intéressant de les
voir parler les voir parler sur ce cas
de ce qu'elles font voilà alors on a
bien entendu le message plutôt désabusé
un de cette jeune femme mais d'autres
ont fait on fait avancer les choses donc
bah oui ou le dixième à nom des
mannequins ont voulu parler on rit la
parole et ont revendiqué leur stature
regarder cette archive de 1965 à
l'époque en france on a répertorié
environ 5000 mannequin est juste ici
vous avez micheline renault elle est
présidente et fondatrice du syndicat des
mannequins et elle vient donc avec
d'autres mannequins au ministère du
travail de l'époque pour rencontrer le
ministre du général de gaulle qui
s'appelle gilbert grandval
nous avons de grands problèmes et ici
chez des familles mannequin qui sont
avec moi qui représente paris lille
grenoble est calme et nous avons des
problèmes de sécurité sociale
d'allocations familiales je n'ai pas eu
à découvrir que ce syndicat était
constituée par des personnes à 10 ans
j'ai eu à découvrir que qu'elles ont
leurs problèmes leurs problèmes
professionnels et qu'elle avait raison
fait encore ses problèmes d'avenir
travail alors des fameux ravissante mais
en tout cas qui n'ont ni allocations
familiales ni protection sociale ça
montre une chose en 1965 mannequin ce
n'est pas un métier c'était pas
considérée juridiquement non et je crois
qu'il se passe en 1969 pour que le
statut de mannequin soit reconnue mais
effectivement on voit que même le
ministre will est réduit à des créatures
gravissant tout excès un peu moins
propre exactement alors même si la
profession et est déprécié ça n'empêche
pas certaines jeunes filles d'être très
motivée pour y arriver qu'à absolument
très motivé mais parce que le rêve c'est
ce qui accompagne cette profession
depuis le début être une femme mannequin
peut rapporter de l'argent mais il faut
voir à quel prix on parlait en tout cas
une jeune mannequin parler comme elle
était considérée comme de la pâte à
modeler et bien vous allez voir une
archive assez hallucinante elle date de
1961 on est dans une école de
mannequinat et un journaliste une
journaliste plutôt va rencontrer la
directrice de cette école et elle va lui
expliquer comment elle va transformer
une jeune femme en mannequin
est ce que vous pourriez le faire sur
cette une fine analyse critique et niel
elle est trop forte pour la taille nous
avons 75 cm c'est trop fort pour les
hanches
98 d'un gang était trop s'il faut
aplatir creuser tout ça il faut donc la
faire maigrir il faut la faire vibrer
évidemment il faut affiner le coup lui
même et empâté voyez-vous tout ça le
coût peut devenir plus long il est
empaqueté parce que trop épais d'ici le
bas du visage et empâté ça se fait très
bien maigrir avec les berck de plats que
lomé togo visage le maquillage vulgaire
évidemment outre et les faussement
entrée qui permettait la coiffure le
chignon d'avoir mal fait le chignon ne
lui va pas bon alors on voit d'abord
qu'il faut pas être susceptible 1 pour
vouloir devenir mannequin et puis
ensuite ça révèle quand même quelque
chose c'est la volonté déjà dans les
années 60 d'uniformiser le corps des
mannequins oui d'avoir finalement une
armée de fille extrêmement
similaires et du coup interchangeables
aussi puisque c'est un métier très
éphémère mais c'est marrant parce que
cet archipel rejoue tous les stéréotypes
qu'on a c'est simplement le on parle
simplement de corps on parle de main sur
un objet c'est un objet oui et c'est un
objet où on l'a on réactualise à nouveau
ses idéaux de la maigreur maigreur
minceur qui vient dire aussi jeunesse
mais elles sont réduites effectivement à
des objets en tout cas ces archives leur
valide heureusement les choses changent
un petit peu ensuite la mini oui surtout
donc fin des années soixante années 70
on parle de certaines mannequins elles
vont avoir un prénom une petite
révolution dans le milieu exemple avec
twiggy cette magnifique mannequin
anglaise qui donc amorcer une sorte de
mouvement est-ce que ça ça a commencé à
changer le métier de mannequin de
pouvoir donner un prénom à ces femmes
c'est insensé comme le processus de
starification d'un coup on a la
notoriété on a un nom on est reconnus on
est payé parce qu'on a un nom quelques
mannequins mais il ya encore beaucoup
d'anonymes ont quelques unes vont être
connus vont avoir un nom et vont avoir
un salaire digne de ce nom j'allais
venir à cette époque les profils des
mannequins finalement évolué oui il y a
de plus de diversité et notamment une
diversité de couleurs des grands
créateurs vont amorcer ce changement
l'un des précurseurs c'est yves saint
laurent on voit un de ces défilés dont
les années 80 justement où on voit
toutes ces mannequins noirs on voit
d'ailleurs c'était une des égéries
d'yves saint laurent
katusha c'est à ce moment là qu'on voit
arriver les super top model ou est
exactement les fameuses top model qu'on
connaît tous alors claudia schiffer
carla bruni naomi campbell qu'on voit
défiler sous nos yeux elles vont de
représenter une époque une génération
ses femmes ses mannequins sont des stars
elles sont même plus célèbre que les
créateurs eux-mêmes elles ont cette fois
un prénom et elles ont un nom et elles
sont invités sur les plateaux de
télévision en france face à des
journalistes un petit peu déconcentré le
dicton du jour à la sainte herbert je
reçois h y faire
avec aucun studio n'est jamais vu autant
de monde un vendredi soir même des
directeurs ses dires le mannequin le
mieux planer payé de la planète vous
troublez déjà claudia schiffer un vrai
plaisir celui de recevoir sur son
plateau ce soir naomi cambell bonsoir
comment expliquez vous que les top
modèles sont en train de devenir
peut-être plus célèbres et les actrices
de cinéma alors passe quelque chose
actuellement quand même hein ce monde il
se passe quelque chose les gens se
soient un provisionnement intéressés à
nous
voilà les gens se sont intéressés à nous
est ce qu'à ce moment-là ça montre que
les mannequins rendre un petit peu dans
la culture populaire elles rendent
totalement la culture populaire dans les
années 90 c'est un véritable tournant
même à rome dans les années 80 et c'est
aussi un tour dans l'industrie de la
mode il ya de plus en plus les créateurs
deviennent des stars et les mannequins
aussi ont un nom alors elles sont même
comme vous l'avez dit plus célèbre que
les créateurs et on a ce top 6 est super
modèle qui vont être construites et qui
vont être construites comme des stars
qui ont un nom un prénom qui vont avoir
des punchline célèbres comme linda
evangelista qui dira qu'elle ne se lève
pas pour moins de dix mille dollars par
an exactement donc là on voit
effectivement c'est un renversement
total c'est la seule profession une des
seules presque même où les femmes
gagnent plus que les hommes on en
parlait aussi déjà dans les journaux
regarde cette année 95 les top models
sont devenus un véritable phénomène
elles ont même remplacé les stars du
grand écran en 94 selon le magazine
américain forbes
cindy crawford a gagné 32 millions de
francs suivi de près par claudia
schiffer 26 millions et demi qu'est ce
qui t'a linton peu près 25 millions
linda evangelista 15 millions et pauvres
naomi campbell guy millions seulement
ce qui est intéressant c'est véritable
ça représente effectivement la mode des
années 90 on en parlait mais c'est
effectivement l'arrivée des gros groupes
ya beaucoup plus d'argent dans le luxe
qui ai mis le luxe devient un gros
spectacle qui est plus qu'un simple
spectacle souvent élitiste ans un
spectacle qui fait de beaucoup d'image
qui circulent dans l'espace public qui
doivent être vus qu'ils doivent faire
rêver et donc elle participe sll sont
les pions essentiels de ce rêve donc
effectivement ils ont la rétribution qui
va avec et pour faire encore monter la
sauce au monde qu'elle gagne de l'argent
qui fuit ce qui finalement engrange
encore plus de rêves et engrange encore
plus de vocations qui vont finalement se
frotter à la dure réalité où il y a des
millions de prétendantes mais seulement
quelques élus et très peu d'élus est
finalement beaucoup de prétendantes qui
vont rester dans la précarité alors
aujourd'hui camille à cette demande que
les mannequins finalement on ressemble
davantage aux femmes de la société oui
alors c'est une injonction qui est fait
au nom de la mode les mannequins doivent
ressembler à la rue être moins maigre
plus rondes représenter tous les styles
toutes les femmes jean paul gaultier a
fait défiler des silhouettes différentes
comme vous le voyez ici en 2010 avec
beth ditto alors j'ai une question
peut-être un peu naïve mais si les
mannequins doivent ressembler à la rue
doivent lui ressembler à quoi elles
servent à ses internautes en réalité
d'ailleurs le mot mannequin est arrivé
dans un second temps à la base on disait
des sosies donc véritablement au départ
le but c'était qu'elle ressemble à la
cliente non que la cliente puisse ce
projet s'identifier après on est tombé
dans effectivement décor avec des
mensurations ce inatteignable qu'on est
tombé dans un an peut-être trop de rêve
dans les années 80-90 qu'on est revenue
à des choses autres jean paul gaultier
c'est un bon exemple parce que
finalement il n'a jamais été dans les
travers de faire encore unifiée est
inatteignable a toujours montré la
différence est ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui avec tous les scandales
sexuels qu'on a entendu les scandales
aussi d'anorexie est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est une profession qui fait
toujours rêver ça c'est une bonne
question parce qu'effectivement je pense
aussi depuis mis tout il ya eu un petit
à petit mis tous dans la mode il était
très petit au niveau des mannequins en
2010 8 la parole elle n'est pas encore
complètement libéré il ya encore
beaucoup de rapports de force de
rapports de pouvoir qu'il faut
déconstruire effectivement dans la mode
et le rêve fonctionne encore l'industrie
de la mode passe une bonne industrie qui
fait rêver en tout cas merci à vous
manon renault journalistes spécialisés
de la mode et enseignant à la sorbonne
de ce regard différent sur le les
mannequins et le mannequinat et merci
avocat me toxique font ce travail voilà
on se quitte avec notre traditionnel
pépite en chanson que vous connaissez
forcément la danse des canards
interprété par lionel en 1981 c'est la
danse des canards les gamins jouent pas
bon dans ccb refrain dans tous les coins
ne soyez pas en retard car la danse des
canards
c'est le tube
il suffit de fermer son bec en mettant
ses procès
je me souviens effet points ça y est
vous avez compris attention c'est pas
fini nous avons jusqu'au matin
voilà c'est aussi ça l'inattendu on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine sur le
canal 27 d'ici là sur les réseaux
sociaux que ce soit ce dinars ou ceux de
france info émission préparée avec les
documentalistes et mini galtier pascal
aubaret merci à elle merci à vous d'être
là chaque semaine
[Musique]